ALFRED FULLER: So, my name is
Alfred Fuller, and I'm going to
talk about Next Gen Queries.
So who am I?
I'm the software engineer on
the Datastore App Engine Team.
I work mostly with
the Query Planner.
I helped remove the
thousand-entity limit
for queries, I added --
[APPLAUSE]
ALFRED FULLER: Thank you.
I added cursors and
prefetching, and I've done lot
of work in the Python and Java
SDK around the datastore, so
I'm familiar with both.
So if you want to follow
along with the wave notes,
you all know the drill.
The bitly link is
NextGen/Queries/Wave.
I would also highly recommend
looking at some past talks.
I'm gonna briefly go over some
concepts that were gone over in
detail, especially in Building
Scalable, Complex Apps on App
Engine by Brett Slatkin last
year, and also there's Under
the Covers of the Google App
Engine Datastore by
Ryan Barrett, which is
excellent as well.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is overview some of
the features we're adding.
These are the largest set of
features that we're adding to
the datastore query engine
since its launch, so these
are fairly substantial.
I'm going to go over some
background of how we run these
queries and then talk about the
technology we use to improve
upon what we already have, and
mainly this is Zigzag Merge
Join and what we
call MultiQuery.
And then I wanna talk about
some -- I'll give you a few
examples, which are probably
not very practical, but they're
very interesting, so I'll let
you guys put them to practical
use, and then talk about some
corollaries that came out of
some of the same technologies
that went into adding
these features.
So the current system is
incredibly scalable.
It's also schema-less so
it's incredibly flexible.
It does the scaling
automatically, and with that,
we are able to perform many
query operations such as
equality filters, inequality
filters, sorts, and through the
magic of composite indexes,
we're able to do many of
these on the same query.
These usually require a
composite index whenever you're
trying to do a combination of
these filters and you have to
plan for those ahead of time,
but you can do a lot of
different things with these.
They're very flexible.
And everything's combined with
a logical AND operator, except
in the case when there are no
sorts and they're all equality
filters, then its free rein.
You can do whatever you want,
although you might want to add
composite indexes if you
want to make it faster and
give some read-and-write
performance tradeoffs.
So how are we improving this?
First thing we're going to do
is we're going to add support
for arbitrary query logic.
So AND, OR, NOT subexpressions,
so you can use the whole
gambit, everything that you
can do, you know, with your
sequel queries and stuff.
I know that we
announced that today.
There's definitely
-- or yesterday.
This is definitely
different from what you
expect in a sequel.
There are still limitations,
especially the
single-inequality
filter limitation.
But we're not leaving the
datastore behind, especially
since it's -- what can
automatically scale, you
know, with no supervision,
which is why we like It.
We're also adding first-class
support for domain-specific
queries, such as Geo-Queries,
Date Range queries, and this
can actually be extended to do
multiple-inequality filters on
numeric properties, or anything
that can be normalized
to zero and one.
The main thing, the thing that
makes this all possible, is
improvements to the
composite indexes.
So we're gonna reduce
the requirements on
composite indexes.
We're going to eliminate the
exploding index problem.
I don't know, how many
of you run into the
exploding index problem?
00:03:52,358 --> 00:03:52,138
[APPLAUSE]
ALFRED FULLER: And we're gonna
have fewer indexes serve a lot
more queries so you can really
balance this, and this makes
composite index selection
kind of a dark art.
Not that it wasn't already,
but even more so.
And we really want to provide
tools to help you do this, but
right now, I think you're gonna
have to rely on this talk, so
you can refer to it
later on YouTube.
And the composite index
selection really provides the
wrench to decide between space
and speed, between
write-and-read latency in
costs, where you want spend
this based on what your
application does.
And first and foremost,
although last in this overview,
none of these result stats were
pulled into memory during any
time during the making
of these features.
So these are scalable, they do
use low resources, and we're
very happy about that.
Quick disclaimer: So,
unfortunately, this is Next Gen
Queries, so it's not in the
current release or
the next release.
We're rolling out these
features in pieces.
The infrastructure's there,
but we have -- it takes time
to expose them to users.
That being said, you can feel
free to use all your Bluetooth
devices and cell phones because
this is only a presentation.
Although some of the back-end
changes are available today,
and I'll go over exactly what
those are, and those are the
ones that are likely to come
out first, so the exploding
index problem should be solved
as soon as I can get to it.
So throughout this
presentation, I'm gonna be
talking -- or using the model
Photo, which has a owner or
person who posted the picture;
a tag, which is a multivalued
property or a list of
user-assigned tags; people,
which can be either user
assigned or if they're facial
recognition; location, which is
where the photo was
taken, and the date.
And this is what I normally
look like over there when I'm
not trying to be presentable.
I was told I was the only
with a tie today so
maybe I went overboard.
Not the pug, not the pug.
That's my wife's cruel
joke again, our dog.
So for some background,
what we use to solve
every query are indexes.
These are the contained index
data, which is a set of ordered
values that are then, when they
are placed in the index, they
are sorted lexigraphically.
So it's a sorted collection of
the index data, and so this is
exactly -- or an example of
what the -- silent
mode, please.
That was my wife.
I think she heard the
comment about the dog.
So this is the built-in
property index.
So it has the kind, the name of
the property, the value of the
property, and the key of the
entity that it's referring to.
This is what a composite
index looks like.
It has the index ID of the
composite index that it's
using, a composite value,
and then the key.
So queries are converted into
scans over these indexes
through the Query Planner, and
this is done by splitting the
index data into two different
pieces: a prefix that's held
constant and a postfix that's
different for each result.
So all the equality filters
that go into the prefix, the
sort orders that go into the
postfix, and inequality filters
are just range restrictions on
that postfix, which is
why we only allow one.
And so for easy example, select
"FROM Photo WHERE tag
equals family." We decide
to split the index data
between the value and key.
We apply a post -- or prefix
constraints of kind equals
photo, name equals tag, value
equals "family," and
this assures that we only see
index rows that refer to photos
that have these properties.
Then we let the key vary.
We use this key to look up the
actual entity, and we return
the photo to you
as a result set.
So, as you can see, since this
is lexigraphically sorted,
these photos are actually
coming out in postfix ordering
in this case, which
is key ascending.
So if we wanted to change that
ordering, we wanted to SELECT
FROM Photo ORDER BY date
DESCENDING, we would choose a
slightly different separation
of these index data.
We subdivide it between
the name and the value.
We apply the prefix constraints
of kind equals photo, name
equals date, which this is an
implied existence filter, so if
it doesn't have a date, it
won't show up in this
index, and then we
let the postfix vary.
And you can see that if we do
the encoding correctly, we
encode this so that date
descending becomes
lexigraphically date
descending in order.
When we pull off the key, we
can look at the photo, and we
get everything with the postfix
ordering of data descending,
key ascending, which is
how we serve this query.
We get a little bit
more complicated.
SELECT FROM Photo WHERE tag
equals "family" AND
tag equals "outside,
ORDER BY date.
Now this requires a composite
index so the first thing we
have to do is we specify
a composite index on
tag, tag, and date.
We choose to split this index
data in the middle of the
composite value between
the last tag and date.
We set our prefix constraints
tag equals "family"
and tag equals
"outside," and we
let the postfix vary.
So we have a postfix ordering
of date descending, key
ascending, and we get the
photos in this order.
Are you still with me?
00:09:37,618 --> 00:09:37,32
Good.
Awesome.
So we expand on this in
two ways, one of which is
with Zigzag Merge Join.
So currently, this
is how it operates.
Zigzag Merge Join can
efficiently find postfix
common to multiple scans.
It produces intermediate false
results because it does two
scans or multiple scans to find
the postfixes that are in
common, but it knows how to
skip past sections of large,
not matching results so it
tends to scale in the size of
the result set instead
of the size of each
individual subscan.
So say we have photos that are
tagged with dogs, photos that
are tagged with cats, and we
would want to find photos that
show dogs and cats
living together.
Well, Zigzag Merge Join can
efficiently find when that
correlates with mass hysteria.
So here's an example
of Zigzag Merge Join.
SELECT FROM Photos WHERE tag
equals "family" AND
tag equals "outside."
Notice there are all only
equality filters here and
there's no sort order so we can
service this query with
Zigzag Merge Join with
only the built-in indexes.
So we're gonna run two queries,
or two index scans, I mean, on
the property index, one -- OK,
we'll split these index data in
the same place for each query
between value and key.
We'll apply a prefix constraint
of kind equals photo, name
equals tag, value equals
"family" for the
first scan, and we'll apply a
prefix constraint of
"photo tag" and
"outside."
So the first scan will give
us all photos that are
00:11:10,82 --> 00:11:10,798
tagged with family.
The second scan will give
us all photos that are
tagged with outside.
Then we apply a postfix
constraint using Zigzag Merge
Join to say that the first
scan's key must equal the
second scan's key for
there to be a match.
So they become one.
We run the scan through the
magic of Zigzag Merge Join,
which is gone over in detail in
Brett's Slatkin's doc, and we
have our photos that match this
query in key ascending order.
MultiQuery is the second
technology we use to
expand upon this.
MultiQuery combines
multiple-query result sets
using a prority queue based on
the orders of the query itself,
and I've nearly optimized it to
avoid the need for this
priority queue when possible,
and it currently just
supports IN and NOT EQUAL.
This is how we
implemented these two.
So if you look at a query where
tag IN "family" or
"friends," ORDER BY
date DESCENDING, this query is
supposed to return any photos
that are either tagged
family or friends.
We split into two different
queries where one has all the
family and the other one has
all the ones that are tagged
with friends, and each result
-- a result from either one of
these queries is a correct
result and is returned to the
user, and we maintain the
ordering because both of these
subqueries have the same
ordering that was on the
original query, and so we only
need to see the first result,
the top result on each query to
merge these result sets
together appropriately.
The NOT EQUAL, on the other
hand -- I've also recently
expanded this, at least in
Java, sorry, to support NOT
EQUAL on multiple NOT EQUAL
expressions as long as they're
on the same property.
But this is actually expanded
into inequality filters.
And so WHERE tag is less than
"beach," WHERE tag is
greater than "beach"
AND less than
"coworkers," and
WHERE tag is greater than
"coworkers." Now,
hopefully, you see a
problem with this.
This actually does not do
what you think it does.
It doesn't return photos that
are not tagged with beach and
are not tagged with coworkers.
It returns -- these are
multivalued properties, and if
you look at this closely, it
returns photos that have a tag
other than coworkers or beach.
So any other tag, and
that result will be
in your result set.
This does the intuitive thing
when it's the single-valued
property, but when it's a
multivalued property, it
has an unintuitive result.
So the Next Gen features.
Was that clear?
Is everybody caught up?
OK, good.
So the first thing I did,
or we did, was add sort
to Zigzag Merge Join.
So right now, Zigzag Merge
Join doesn't work when
you have a sort order.
Well, it's pretty simple to
expand Merge Join from looking
at just keys to looking
at the entire postfix.
And so we've done that.
And so here's an example of the
same query I showed you earlier
that required the index
on tag, tag and date.
But now we can use
Zigzag Merge Join.
We do two scans or -- OK, we
first -- or we created an
index on tag and date.
We do two scans instead of one.
We divide it between the tag
and date, as I previously
showed you, and then we apply
our prefix constraints.
The first scan is for
"family." The
second scan is for
"outside." We apply
Zigzag Merge Join, which now
can merge both the prefix or
both the date and the key, so
basically the entire postfix,
and then we let that vary.
We pull off the key.
We get the photos in date
descending and key ascending.
Now this is an essential
difference because tag, tag and
date is an exploding index.
Tag and date is not because tag
is a multivalued property.
Another thing we've added,
will add -- sorry, it's not
out yet -- is OR and NOT.
So this is how AND works.
The postfix must equal.
And OR, for this Venn diagram,
we want everything that's in
both of these circles, so we
just don't have a constraint.
Everything that's in
either scan matches.
But Zigzag can also be very
efficient here in which we
never look at the
same key twice.
So it scales on the size of the
blue region, not on the size
of the individual circles.
NOT, on the other hand, is
a little more complicated.
We say one scan's postfix
does not equal a postfix
of another scan's.
This is equivalent
to set subtraction.
So if I want to do NOT just
some subexpression, I would
take everything NOT in
that subexpression.
Everything and NOT(a).
Note, though, that is
not converted into an
inequality expression.
It is not a greater
than or a less than.
This is still an inequality.
So it can be put in the prefix,
thus you can have a sort order
while doing NOT in this case.
And it returns intuitive
results for multivalued
properties, because this is now
set subtraction so it will
do exactly what you
think it will do.
If the photo is tagged with
"coworker" and
"outside," it won't
show up in the result set even
if it has another tag on it.
So here's an example
of actually how we
do this efficiently.
So a and NOT(b), if a is a
result set that contains 2, 3
and 5, and b is a result set
that contains 1, 3 and 4, we
expect the result to
be a set of 2 and 5.
So the algorithm pulls the
first value off of a, which is
2, looks for a value in b that
is greater than our equal to 2,
finds 3, so two matches because
3 is greater than 2, pulls the
next result off of a, finds 3.
We already pulled 3 off of b so
we know that 3 doesn't match.
Then it pulls the next result
off of a, which is 5.
We look for a result in b that
is greater than or equal to 5.
We find none.
Five matches.
We pull the next result
off of a, we find none.
That's the end of
our result set.
So we've only looked at four
out of the six keys to produce
two results, but each one of
these keys that we skipped over
in b can be a large region
of nonmatching results.
So this does tend to scale in
a size of the result set, and
it becomes very efficient,
especially when combined with
many more merge constraints.
So we can go crazy with this.
You can even go -- this is
very actually not that crazy,
now that I look at it.
So (a and b) OR c) AND NOT(d).
This, when all combined
together, runs the
same algorithm.
It's pushed through doing the
same process at the same time
so it does scale in the size of
the blue area, not the area of
any of the sub -- of the other
combinations or of the result
sets from any of those.
So this does scale and you can
get it as complicated as you
want, and it will still tend to
scale in the size
of the blue area.
So another thing that we're
doing is we're adding
OR to MulitQuery.
So WHERE tag IN
"family" or
"friends" or
"person" IN some list
of people, ORDER BY date
DESCENDING, we'll split out,
and you can see it's actually
almost a trivial change where
we just split or we start
saying person equals.
As long as they're sorted by
the same sort properties, the
postfix is the same, thus we
can order them properly when
we merge them using
the priority queue.
Wow, that was awesome.
So if you look at this, you
notice that this actually has
no false positive results.
In fact, MultiQuery never has
a false positive result.
Every result that MultiQuery
returns is a result.
But it does have a lot of
duplicates, or it could have a
lot of duplicates, depending on
the data, because each one of
these subqueries could produce
the exact same results, and we
will have to de-dupe it for
you so that you never see
the same result twice.
So the performance of this OR
versus Zigzag, or MultiQuery
versus Zigzag in general,
depends a lot on the data
because it's a trade-off
between the duplicate
values or the intermediate
false positive results.
Another thing that we've added
or are going to add -- sorry --
are going to add to MultiQuery
is support for a
domain-specific query such as
Geo-Queries and Date
Range queries.
We do this by adding a query
splitter that produces multiple
parallel query components.
And the splitting logic
can be anything, right?
So in the case of Geo and Date
Range, this is done using
a space-filling curve.
So these queries are split out
into regions to scan along this
space-filling curve, and you
can choose the number of
regions you want to scan, which
is the number of queries you
want to run in parallel versus
the accuracy of those regions.
So there's a performance
trade-off there, and when you
choose something besides the
most accurate, you get false
positive results in this case,
so you have to do some pruning.
So we have entity filters.
We always apply a de-duping
filter because that's almost
always needed or always needed
with multiqueries and so
there's a special filter for
the Geo and Date Range Queries
that prunes these
fuzzy results.
So you only see the ones that
exactly match your query,
but it's still done
efficiently through the
space-filling curve.
So here's some examples of how
the Next Gen queries improve
your life as a developer.
So SELECT FROM Photo WHERE tag
equals "family" and
tag equals "outside,"
date DESCENDING.
I use this a lot.
This just means find recent
photos of my family
taken outside.
So for the current gen, it's an
index on tag, tag and date,
which is exploding and doesn't
scale when you have
a lot of tags.
There's a 5,000 index row limit
on the datastore, and your
users might not put in, you
know, 5,000 square-rooted, but,
you know, I wouldn't
trust that.
You know, users do crazy things
sometimes, and maybe there's
enough stuff to tag
in their photos.
So this is dangerous.
This is a dangerous
index to do.
You might have errors that
don't show up in testing, that
don't show up when you're
exploring the possibilities
of using the datastore.
But on the Next Gen, you only
require the index on tag and
date so it does not
explode anymore.
This query SELECT photos WHERE
tag IN "family" or
"friends" and tag
equals "outside,"
and tag does not equal
"beach." "Find
all photos of my friends and
family taken outside but not on
the beach." I didn't
specify a sort order because I
wanted to compare this to the
current generation, and in the
current generation, you
couldn't do this query if you
had a sort order because the
inequality expression of the
NOT EQUAL turns into inequality
filters, which require that
it's sorted on tag, plus you
get unintuitive results because
tag is a multivalued property.
But in the Next Gen, it
requires no additional indexes.
You can run this all only on
the built-in indexes, and you
get the intuitive results.
If I add the filter and convert
this to use OR instead of IN
and subexpressions, so NOT
instead of NOT EQUALS,
NOT and then the term.
So, as I said, this is not
possible in the current
generation, but if you were to
do this in Next Gen, it only
requires that index on
tag and date still.
And this is -- one of the many
features that I think is
incredibly useful because if
you have an index on tag and
date, you can have any number
of tag equality filters in your
query in any combination of OR
and AND, AND NOT, and it
will still be able to
satisfy that query.
So if you have a search box and
someone's typing in what tags
they want to find, I wanna see
these tags, and not those tags,
a user is, before you'd be
restricted on what queries
00:23:29,64 --> 00:23:29,28
you have access to.
If you had a query on tag, tag,
tag and date, you could do
three, but you couldn't do two.
You'd need an index
on tag and date.
And then if you had that one,
it wouldn't support four.
So the only way to dynamically
allow a search box where a user
could enter this and it would
be converted efficiently into a
query is to use the Zigzag
Merge Join, which currently
doesn't allow you to sort.
And now that it does, we
can solve it efficiently.
So we're gonna go really crazy.
Tag IN "family" and
"friends," or people
IN some list of people that are
your family and friends AND tag
equals "outside" AND
NOT tag equals
"beach" OR location
IN the coastal region, ORDER BY
date DESCENDING.
I do not recommend you run this
query, but you could do it.
This is the exact same meaning
of the previous query, but it
does not rely on proper tagging
because you have facial
recognition for people who are
in your the friends and family
contact lists, and you have a
region that you think is near
the beach, thus I assume those
tags are equal, although I
wouldn't trust that either.
But notice, though, that the
NOT is applied to an entire
subexpression, so this is
literally how you can work with
the new Zigzag framework, is it
can be applied to any
subexpression, and it
will do it efficiently.
This does require clever use of
Geo encoding that I plan to
support, or we plan to support.
The team's not very big.
So normally, a location would
be a location query, or a
geospatial query would be an
inequality filter on the
space-filling curve, but you
can, if you encode it correctly
and are clever about it, make
it an inequality expression so
you can actually have that
sort, which allows you to
prioritize, like if you have a
map, you could prioritize what
you see in that map using
this technique as well.
So in the current generation,
it's definitely not possible.
In the next generation, you can
deal with an index on tag and
date, tag and people,
geolocation and date, and
that's all you need.
And those, if you look at them,
can service as a whole slew of
queries, whereas before, when
you were specifying a composite
index, there are very few that
you could actually service
with these queries, or with
these composite indexes.
So when do we use what?
When do we decide to use the
MultiQuery OR, or the Zigzag
OR, or these all seem to
support similar features?
Well it, all depends on
what composite indexes
are given to us, but we
do have a preference.
So Zigzag pretends to produce
results that scale on the size
of the result set, but can in
pathological cases, scale only
in a size of the largest
subscan, while MultiQuery
produces duplicate correct
results but is guaranteed to
scale on the side of the result
set because there are no
false positive results.
Every result you pop off
is a result that is
in the result set.
Although there are duplicates,
but we do have a limit, which
makes that a constant value,
the number of duplicates you
can see, which is kind of
cheating and bad, but it
doesn't scale very well.
So in those cases, we're
going to use Zigzag anyway.
So the actual performance does
depend on the shape of your
data, but when possible, we
will always prefer to run a
full-fledged query, or a
MultiQuery, when we have the
composite indexes there, but
there are many cases in which
this just does not work.
So if we look at the
capabilities of these two
methods, Zigzag, if you ever
talk to me afterwards, is the
answer to everything.
It does a lot of stuff, and
it is very, very flexible,
especially in this case,
whereas MultiQuery has
that unintuitive NOT.
It can only do that on
a single property.
It has a limited number of
filters when you do AND because
you have that composite index
for each number of
those AND filters.
It restricts the number of
queries you can run in parallel
so that OR is a little
restrictive, but it's the only
thing that you can really do to
the main specific queries.
So we'll continue -- so we pick
what to use on what is given to
us and what are the constraints
for each of these methods.
So specifically here, almost
every query can be converted
into a MultiQuery that will
potentially run faster
than the Zigzag except
when we have the NOT.
It's a dividing line where if
you want the intuitive NOT or
you want the NOT on multiple
properties, it'll have to at
some point do the Zigzag
between multiple indexes.
So let's look at how an actual
query will be planned.
So if we have only the built-in
indexes, if we're going to run
this query, it will have to be
done using Zigzag Merge Join.
So we convert this into an AND
operation, we split out the IN
to an OR, we pull out the NOT,
pull out that OR, combine them
all together, and this is
actually the class hierarchy
that we use, and this runs
as a single Zigzag run.
But if you look at this,
we're actually running
a lot of subscans.
So in this case, we're running
five subscans, and each one of
these are very broad, right?
So there's a lot of potential
for false-positive
results in these.
So this may not be efficient if
you have a pathological case, a
specific query, a specific
user-data combination.
So you might want to optimize
this, depending on what kind
of restrictions you want
to place on your users.
So if we add the index, which
is exploding, but if we wanted
to restrict the users to be
5,000 square-rooted, a number
of tags, we can do this with
Multiquery, and in this case,
we'll split out that IN into
two different parallel query
components, tag equals
"family" or tag
equals "friends."
Those are run in
separate queries.
We split out the NOT into their
own separate query components,
and then we run this.
We'll run these queries, and
you can see that we're running
more queries in this case.
There's six of them, but
they're very specific.
They only hit the positive
results so they will
tend to be a lot faster.
Happily, there's
middle ground now.
Before there was no middle
ground, and we're gonna
provide a middle ground.
So in this case, you can just
add an index on tag and tag,
and if we see this, Zigzag will
actually combine the OR and
that one tag equals
"outside" into a
single OR constraint.
So we're only running four
queries now and two of them
are much more specific.
They scan a much smaller
region, have a lot
smaller potential for
false-positive results.
So this allows you to control
the space versus time or
write versus read latency.
By the selection of these
indexes, you can choose where
to optimize your queries.
So say we have these two
queries, and if we had no
composite indexes, they would
be running on three different
scans for each of these and
doing Zigzag to merge them, and
your only choice today is to
add these indexes
to speed them up.
Every time you add an index,
you increase the space that
you're taking up with these
indexes, you're reducing the
time it takes to run these
queries, but you're also
increasing the cost of the
write because each index
requires you to put in an index
row, and when you do that it,
takes up you CPU quota for your
API stuff, and that's very
precious in App Engine, but you
are reducing your read time.
So already available,
you can add this add
this index instead.
So this is the parts that were
common to both of those queries
before so they will run
on these indexes instead.
So today, if you added
the common index, Zigzag
is smart enough to use
that composite index.
And so you really have the
tools to tweak your indexes and
really make them work for you
which, if you can do and
successfully, will probably
make you very valuable
to your company.
So some corollaries to this
work, just some side notes.
So I don't know if any of you
have seen the SearchableModel
class that Ryan wrote, but it
was pretty useful unless you
wanted to sort, and datastore
is meant to scale.
It's meant to have really large
data sets, and those aren't
actually very useful unless
you can sort, unless you can
pull out the most important
results from all the noise.
So now SearchableModel becomes
useful because you can actually
sort, and you can have a user
enter a string that has any
length, and you can service
that query, and it might take
longer to enter like 25 words,
but it will still complete.
You won't get an
index-not-found error or
a need-an-index error,
and it will run.
Another thing you can notice is
that multivalued properties
don't really sort well,
like it's not very
intuitive to sort.
There's almost never a reason
to put them in a sort order.
So given that and given the
fact that you can Zigzag
everything, that you only
require one property at most in
any prefix, although it is
recommended that you put more
than those to optimize for
specific queries, that
means there are no more
exploding indexes.
There's no need to have a
multivalued property repeated
more than once in an exploding
index or in an index so
thus it will not explode.
And so another thing, if you've
been paying attention and I
didn't go too fast, and you
like my pretty slides that are
animated, you'll notice that
the only thing that's different
for each of these results that
was pushed to the users as a
result set was the postfix.
The prefix stayed constant.
And right now for cursors, what
we're actually returning in the
cursor is the index row so we
know where to start the scan
the next time you resume.
So we can look at this, and
we can say we only need to
store the postfix so we can
make these much smaller.
If you think about it for
MultiQuery, the postfixes all
have to be the same because
that determines the ordering,
and all the subqueries have to
use the same ordering to be
able to merge efficiently.
So these cursors can work for
multiqueries as well, although
you will face de-duping issues
across multiple requests
if you do this.
But another thing we can do
is that the only difference
between a date descending index
and a date ascending index is
how the index data is encoded.
So we can store raw properties
in cursors instead of the
encoded values, and that means
that you can run a cursor on an
index that has the ordering
reversed, thus allowing you to
scroll backwards and forwards
in a given result set.
However, this does have
a little catch, got-ya.
Since the final ordering of
every query is key ascending,
you have to explicitly put in
a key descending ordering.
Otherwise, it won't
work properly.
But this does allow you to
page endlessly forwards
and backwards in the
same result set.
So that's it.
Wow, that was way under time.
I was supposed to talks slow,
and I hope it did, But you guys
seem pretty free up there.
I asked a couple of times.
Oh yeah, I'm unplugged.
That's right.
00:36:22,898 --> 00:36:22,438
[LAUGHTER]
ALFRED FULLER: I think
my wife picked it out.
She didn't really
like the ones I had.
Apparently, she likes
to dress up her family
members, including the pug.
So I have mainly been working
on reliability issues right
now, and I really want to
get these out for you.
All the infrastructure is there
so if you were -- if I really
wanted to run these queries
right now, I could, but
exposing them to you and
building all the pipeline that
needs to take it from the APIs,
all the way through to the
back-end datastore, it's
actually a fair amount of work,
and I'll get to it
as soon as I can.
I really want to do this
because -- it's a small team.
But the Zigzag operating on
every query so you can use
SearchableModel will be
out really, really soon.
So that part will be there, but
improving -- like there are
many ways to enter the query so
GQL won't be that hard to
upgrade, but the programmatic
interface for Python and stuff
will have to be completely
changed to support other
things, you know, besides AND,
so that'll take a little work.
But I really want to
get it you guys.
So the query splitter and the
entity filters, they're in the
Java SDK right now, and we're
going to put them in the Python
one and we want to finalize the
API there, and I want to expose
those to users so you can have
your queries work as if
they were our queries.
So the prototype I have right
now for the GeoQueries, let's
just say, point in region.
Like you literally can say
that, and exposing these will
let you do the exact same thing
for your to domain-specific
queries so that you can have
like an SQL-like statement that
will just work, and they'll
have them, so I definitely
do want to expose those.
They aren't right now because
we haven't finalized the API.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I was just
wondering, so like on the Dev
App server, it recommends
indexes to create based
on your run time.
Is that now going to change
because certain indexes aren't
going to be needed for--
ALFRED FULLER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --some of the queries
that the Dev App server's
going to generate?
ALFRED FULLER: Yes,
it will change.
AUDIENCE: And also do we need
to delete manually some of
our composite indexes that
were previously created?
00:38:55,938 --> 00:38:55,8
ALFRED FULLER: Yes.
So it will require refactoring
of your indexes and the Dev App
server will recommend
different indexes.
Notably what it will do is it
will never recommended an index
with a repeated property in it.
So if you have the same
property repeated twice in the
index, we just won't recommend
that, but other than that, it
will always recommend the
fastest index, which is the
very explicit one, right?
But it does -- we'll have to
make it so that it sees the
indexes you already have
and doesn't recommend it
when you don't need it.
AUDIENCE: Yes, now that
SearchableModel class is more
usable, are we able to
essentially do what
are LIKE queries?
ALFRED FULLER: There's a large
domain of full-text search
queries that you can use with
it, but it's not going
to be like queries.
And it's pretty limited.
We are definitely working
on a better solution
for full-text search.
We really want to get that out
to you guys, but for right now,
searchable models like the only
-- I'm not saying you should
use it for sure, but you can
customize and do a similar
model for your type of data
that meets your specific needs.
But no, LIKE is not really
working right now.
So there is a place for sequel
for sure, and it's just to get
it to this scale and make it
scale automatically, there are
still those restrictions.
AUDIENCE: Did you say
in cursors that we
can now go backwards?
Is that what you were saying?
Like the current cursors?
00:40:38,578 --> 00:40:38,018
ALFRED FULLER: Yes.
The current cursors right now
can only go forward, which
means they're very useful when
you're chaining task view tasks
and stuff like that, but if
you're paging through results,
it becomes very much less
useful, and I always wanted
them to be able page both
forwards and backwards
in a result set.
And to do that, it does require
that you have an index that is
basically the reverse of
whatever index you're going
over, but if we encode the raw
values, we can actually find a
spot for that spot in the other
index in the reverse index, and
thus you can scroll forward in
that index, which is
essentially backwards
in the other one.
We can also do things like
here's an entity, tell me where
it is in this index, or just
start on this entity, and we
can actually convert that
entity into a cursor, and
so you can do things
like that as well.
AUDIENCE: That's for
the future, right?
Is that for Python and Java?
ALFRED FULLER: Yeah.
So that's actually on a lower
level than the APIs, so if I
write it for one,
it's for both.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you mentioned
point-in-region queries?
Geospatial queries?
ALFRED FULLER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: That sounds cool.
Is the region like a bounding
box, or is it like a polygon?
ALFRED FULLER: So in the
prototype that I have running,
you can specify a circle,
a bounding box, or a
polyregion, polylines.
AUDIENCE: Polylines.
ALFRED FULLER: And
then you can -- should
I not say this stuff?
00:42:01,83 --> 00:42:01,778
I don't know.
Probably not?
Oh, well, in the prototype I
have running, which is not
necessarily the final
prototype, you can also do --
if you have IN, you can plug
multiple regions in there and
it'll do a union, and you can
end that with another IN, and
it will do an intersection of
the regions, so you could do
any sort of combination of
these regions as well.
AUDIENCE: Could you explain
what you meant when you said
the only difference between
an ascending and descending
index is the encoding?
ALFRED FULLER: Yeah, sure.
So the indexes we have are
sort of lexigraphically
by-the-byte encoding, right?
So an integer value, depending
on whether it's a big Indian or
little Indian, you know, it
kind of will mess with that.
So we have special encodings,
right, so that if you have like
an integer, it will encode
it such that one is first,
two is second in a byte.
That's why they're
fixed length, right?
And so when you do a descending
decoding, it sorts it in the
opposite direction so it's like
255 minus all of those bytes.
So they're encoded differently.
And right now, cursors store
the encoded value and not the
raw value, which is why we can
disencode them differently
on the back end.
And we do have a plan.
We do have plans to
support full-text search.
The main problem is
we have many plans.
Well, actually, the problem is
that we have multiple solutions
for this internally, and none
of them really fit App
Engine quite right.
And they don't mesh exactly,
and getting them to mesh, and
making sure that that mesh is
solid and that the user will
have a good experience, is
actually very difficult.
So that's what we're working on
right now is we're testing
these solutions and making sure
that they will work correctly
for you guys before
we release them.
So that's why we
don't have it yet.
00:44:10,258 --> 00:44:10,178
[INAUDIBLE]
ALFRED FULLER: Oh, yeah?
The gear?
Yeah, for some reason, the
encoding of this stuff is kinda
weird on here like that one.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALFRED FULLER: Which one?
Where?
[INAUDIBLE]
ALFRED FULLER:
Presentation view.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALFRED FULLER: As soon as
possible for that one if I can
parse that one correctly.
[READING___QUEST
ION___FROM___SCREEN]
ALFRED FULLER: Are there any
short-term plans to allow
filtering by more than
one inequality filter?
So theoretically, the
space-flowing curve, like the
Hilbert curve, can be expanded
into any dimensionality space,
although the higher the
dimensionality, the less
efficient your query is going
to be, and the harder the
encoding of these indexes.
I mean, you'll need more
bytes to get more accuracy
for that encoding.
But theoretically, you can take
the Hilbert curve and use that
to do any property or to apply
multiple inequality filters to
any property that can be
normalized to like a zero and
one range, which does not
include strings, right, or --
theoretically it doesn't
include real numbers, but, you
know, for floating point
numbers it's definitely
possible because
there is a max.
So for right now, I plan on
adding support for two because
it actually maps very well to
the size of an integer field,
64 bits, and in the future, I
will try to add more as well.
So this actually is really
useful for date range problems
where you have a start and end
date, you know, and you want to
find everything that overlaps
this other range for the start
and end date, which is actually
a very common problem.
So those will be supported
by two so we can do those.
00:46:30,94 --> 00:46:30,26
[READING___QUEST
ION___FROM___SCREEN]
ALFRED FULLER: Is it impossible
to add MapReduce queries like
in -- so the MapReduce
frameworks should use cursors
and cursors work with all these
queries so you should be able
to use MapReduce over an query.
If you saw the talk earlier,
if you didn't, it was very
good, by Mike [? Atasky. ?]
And I would recommend you watch
it on YouTube if you haven't.
I think it's much more
closer to the arrows.
You know, the NOT EQUALS
when it's like less than,
greater than because that's
pretty much what it is.
And before all this work, it
wasn't really possible to do
anything but what it does.
And so it was kind of assumed
that we should just put it in
and since that's the only thing
that's possible, then it
wouldn't ever -- well, it would
definitely cause confusion, but
people testing their work would
see that, and it would
happen like that.
And it's going to be difficult
pushing into the future
to decide when to
switch them around.
I think that way, if you
specify NOT, if you specify NOT
explicitly, we're going to use
Zigzag every time, or if we
can't do your query, we're
going to use Zigzag, and in
other cases, we're going to
assume they're single-value
properties and do that because
that would be the most
efficient way to do it.
Well, this is all going to have
to be -- apparently, there's
differences between GQL and the
programmatic query framework,
and personally, I recommend you
use the programmatic query
framework because it's not
string parsing and stuff.
Why do that because Python
is all about the string
parsing and lookups.
But we're going to have to
rework all this to support the
Next Gen so we definitely want
parity between the two, future
parity between this and Java,
and Java has JDO and JPA, which
have all their own query
languages, which are much more
rich than GQL and we'll
definitely try also to support
that natively, all these
features natively
in there as well.
So none of this is
really published.
In fact, I don't think our
internal documentation for it
is very good either, as, Ryan
probably hates me for, because
he's always encouraged me to do
that, and especially if a bus
crashed and I was in it, I
think you guys would
be all out of luck.
So I think this is the
documentation, like
you should watch the
YouTube video for now.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALFRED FULLER: Yeah, we are
definitely looking for
people to add to the team.
I don't know what that is.
OLAP?
[INAUDIBLE]
ALFRED FULLER: Okay, cool.
Well, thank you all for coming.
If you have any more specific
questions or anything like
that, please come and see me.
I am happy to answer
any of your questions.
Thank you very much.